-Our next guest is a Tony
and Emmy Award-winning actress
you know from shows
such as "The West Wing"
and "Pushing Daisies"
and from Broadway productions
like "Wicked" and
"On the 20th Century."
She stars in the second
season of "Schmigadoon!",
which premieres
Wednesdays on Apple TV+.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Kristin Chenoweth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You -- I mean, your
very personality sparkles,
but for you to also wear
an outfit that does...
-Listen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm showing up
for the Seth Meyers show, okay?
I see you didn't.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know I love you.
-How dare you? How dare you?
I would look ridiculous
in your outfit.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is --
This is a wonderful show.
We've talked about
the first season with you
over the years --
And not over the years,
but the second season --
and the first year
that you did this show
was very difficult.
It was in the middle of COVID,
hard core protocols.
-Yes. We wore cones like dogs.
-[ Laughs ]
It was very unfair to make
a star like you wear a cone.
-I know.
I was like, "Sit? Okay.
Eat? Alright."
[ Laughter ]
That's what it felt like.
Sorry.
-And you -- you were
right across the hall
in a hotel from your friend
and costar, Alan Cumming.
-Yes.
-But this year,
a bit of an upgrade --
not over Alan,
but over the living arrangement.
-[ Laughs ]
-You shared a home
with Cecily Strong.
-Yeah, so I was in the Sutton,
this -- our hotel.
I call it the "Slutton."
[ Laughter ]
-This is a -- Let's go a little
deeper on the Slutton.
This is -- This
is a hotel in Vancouver
that everybody --
-You who know it well.
-I know it.
Everybody who's working
on a production up there,
of which there are many --
-We all stay there.
-And they all show up
in the hotel bar.
-Yeah. And we all do the bar,
and we all do the workout
and we call it the Slutton.
And I think it's because
people act like sluts there.
-Yeah.
-I'm not sure it does.
-Like, I feel like
of the places
I've been in my life,
"what happens here, stays here"
was far truer of the
Slutton than it is of Las Vegas.
-Absolutely, baby.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, yeah.
So I lived next door to Alan
in the Slutton -- Sutton and...
and this year I was upset
because my dog -- there was
an issue with my dog.
Anyway, Cecily said, "You want
to come live with me?"
And I'm like, "Absolutely,"
because she is like me.
We're both bat [bleep],
but we love each other.
[ Laughter ]
-Dog lovers as well.
-I mean, her dog is like my dog.
I just --
I loved living with her.
She said it was a little
"Flowers in the Attic."
She said, "You can stay
in the basement."
[ Laughter ]
So I lived down there.
There was a gym, not that --
neither one of us
ever touched it,
but there was a gym
and there was no light.
I'm one of those sleepers
that likes to sleep
with not one little
piece of light.
There was no light.
And I literally
was like a vampire.
I would -- I was upside
down asleep every night.
And she would -- I would come up
in the mornings and she'd go,
"You're a real va--
like, you're a bat."
Like, "I know."
We would watch all of our shows.
-So you have --
That's very important.
You have similar
tastes in shows?
-Have you met her?
-Yeah, I have.
-Okay. So we both love the
housewives of any county.
-Okay. You're not picky.
-Not picky.
And we were obsessed
with the Salt Lake City.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, there was --
There was some criminal
activity, right?
-Do you know what's going on?
-I only know
there's maybe been some arrests.
-Yes, Seth.
-It's very fun.
I have this very nice thing
where I'm just on the outside
of understanding
anything in that world,
but I appreciate that
if I get in, I'll never get out.
-You'll never get out.
-They say it's like
going in Cecily's basement.
Once you're there...
-[ Laughs ]
You never come out!
So we would get this --
She said, "I have this vodka
and it's organic."
I was like,
"I'm all -- That's good.
Organic vodka."
-I did not know
they all weren't.
-I -- [ Laughs ]
Because, right?
-Yeah.
-How do you make --
How do you -- That...?
-It feels like they've all
been wiped with an alcohol swab.
-It's one big alcohol.
-Yeah.
-So anyway, we'd sit there
and we watch --
So first of all,
I love the housewives.
They make me feel better
about my own life.
-Uh-huh.
-And I've actually become
friends with a couple of them.
If you like "Housewives
of Salt Lake City" like I do,
Heather Gay has a wonderful
book called "Bad Mormon."
You should read it.
And it's not about
Heather, is it?
Anyway, back to me.
[ Laughter ]
She -- She's
a delightful person.
But there's this girl
on there named Jen Shah,
and I know some of you ladies
and probably some of you men
know what I'm talking about.
She actually stole --
she accidentally stole
from old people.
[ Laughter ]
-She accidentally --
She sound like one
of Donald Trump's lawyers.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way,
you're Lindsey Graham
and Donald Trump
can be Tony Award-worthy.
-Thank you very much!
And you have a Tony,
so that means a lot.
I will ask for a quote
for you for the poster.
-Done. I mean, it was good.
-Wait, what about -- It seems
like there's a lot happening
in the world of the Vanderpumps.
-Oh!
Oh.
-Okay.
So again, I sort of, you know,
a headline --
as a headline spotter only,
I realize there's
sort of a storm brewing.
Is this something
we should all try
to engage ourselves
in this story?
Is it worth...?
-Well, if you like yourself.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-There is a long-term
couple on their named
Tom and named Ariana.
Now I'm fixing to get a shirt
that says Team Ariana.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I did
"Watch What Happens Live."
I've probably done that...
Andy's a good friend of mine.
I've done that show a lot
because I am --
I know the Bravo shows,
like "Married at First Sight."
Come on, that's a car wreck
waiting to happ--
I just love it.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, they broke up
because her good friend
is cheating with Tom.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And I did "Watch What Happens"
with him, and he always seemed
a little smarmy to me.
And there you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Well, you know what?
I don't know anything,
but Team Ariana as well.
-Yes!
-I'm jumping on.
-Thank you.
-I'm with you.
I have a bunch more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from my friend
Kristin Chenoweth.